[Music]
[Applause]
let's go to Chris Sims pro football talk
live co-host and of course his podcast
unbuttoned former NFL Texas quarterback
you know speaking of Texas I was
thinking about you today because your
dad of course great quarterback
borderline Hall of Famer and you being
his son you're a big recruit you go to
Texas and now you have Arch Manning with
his dad and his you know family lineage
and I'm wondering now you went your
first year and sat and then major Apple
White and you I think split time your
sophomore year if that sounds right Arch
Manning goes there he just played a
little bit I don't know if Quinn ERS is
coming back to Texas but could you see a
scenario where arch Manning transfers
from
Texas it'll it'll be interesting it will
be you know I mean he certainly got some
competition there it's not going to it
doesn't look like it's just going to be
the red carpet is going to be rolled out
for him right right you know so it it's
hey nothing's going to be given to you
in big-time college football you're
going to have to compete and do that I
learned that like you said I made my
first start actually my freshman year in
the bonfire game at Texas A&M right that
was quite the experience to be cool and
a part of it but then yeah sophomore
year split time with major and had to
deal with all that and then junior year
became the starter full-time but uh the
one thing I'll say about Archie Manning
or Arch Manning I should say is man just
watching him the other night he really
looked like his grandfather in a lot of
ways I I thought he looked more like
Archie Manning than he did Payton or Eli
the way he ran and everything even the
way he throws the football uh but yeah
we'll see where it goes there you know
there there's uh I'm blanking on the
other kid's name at Texas that took over
for yours uh he's a he's looks like he's
got some talent and some big time upside
as well but this is different though
your freshman year you're not starting
there was no transfer portal and if you
did transfer you had to sit out of year
Arch Manning could transfer you know the
offseason and go to Old Miss or Ohio
State or any of these places now I he he
shouldn't be afraid to do whatever he's
got to do to put himself in the right
position you know that's what I would
say it's big business right how you you
know where you are the support you have
playing getting that experience playing
and playing and playing makes you a
better football player and that's what
he's got to make his number one priority
you know which I'm sure his number one
goal is to get to the NFL that's the
most important thing Malik Murphy is the
Malik Murphy there it is I know I I I
was going to say Malik and then I was I
was afraid to say the last name I wasn't
sure if I was right there I was blanking
where are we at this point in the
NFL we're at a point right now in the
NFL where I feel like you know we've
seen the I think we know who the cream
of the crop is I think we know the teams
that can legitimately win the Super Bowl
okay how many how many are there that
could win the Super Bowl not go win yeah
right yeah I'd say you know I'd say
there's eight maybe I'd say about eight
right now right that's where I kind of
look at it all right let's run down the
teams okay all right so you got Kansas
City yep AFC right all right so let's go
conference in the AFC I go let's go
Kansas City
Baltimore Jacksonville Miami I look at
those four teams and go they can win the
Super Bowl right Buffalo's not in there
I'm not going to put buffalo in there
it's it's the it's too much of a oneman
show right I Super Bowl's got to be
about a team you know it's it's it's
can't be one guy doing everything for
the team and then the rest of the team
fails him and then for some reason
everybody blames him I don't know it's a
crazy thing that's a different topic for
a different time but then in the NFC I
kind of look at yeah the Eagles the
49ers
Dallas and I'll throw Detroit in there
even though I do think Detroit's got
some cracks in the armor that I'm a
little concerned about but you know I do
think there's enough talent and coaching
there that they could write the ship
write the ship excuse me I was watching
n Season Hard Knocks last night with the
Miami Dolphins yeah Tyreek Hill and he's
the feature Tyreek if if Kevin Hart
could play
football he would be Tyreek Hill Tyreek
Hill is fascinating during a game
because and there's a little bit of
Ricky Henderson in him because he talks
to himself the whole time like I'm here
I'm here I'm here all day Tyreek here
all day I fascinated with watching him
and that speed when you're field level
speed it is so different than when
you're watching on TV or in the stands
it's like wow there's there's nobody
like him nobody a lot of great a lot of
greats talk in the third person right
that's what I've learned through my time
in sports uh and I love that and that's
what makes them great you know he has
fun he's loose right why well cuz he's
the best damn Athlete on the football
field so he's like this is fun look at
me nobody can do what I can and yeah
this is where I fought with the masses a
few years back when I was like Tyreek
Hill's the best receiver in football I I
don't care if he doesn't run the exact
most precise routes like some of the
other receivers in football he's the
greatest weapon you know arguably we've
ever seen at the wide receiver position
and I think his speed is wait you would
put him above Randy Moss no I'd say he's
right up there in that discussion though
I do think he's right there with it yeah
I he is he is on a Hall of Fame pace and
you know I think he's the MVP of
football right now you know everything
they do it's all dictated because of him
and what he brings to that offense
that's where he's special uh you know
he's incredible personal incredible
worker that's the other thing I know
about Tyreek Hill I mean he gets after
it he expects a lot from himself and
yeah he's unbelievable football player I
love when you hear the dialogue I mean
really it's just NFL films is what hard
KNX is you know they're just capturing
this audio but they don't realize how
great Max Crosby is of the Raiders CU
he's in the back field and that's why I
think sacks are overrated pressures
hurries I think that's really an
important stat Max Crosby is just there
he's omnipresent you're even like two is
even acknowledging this Tyreek Hill goes
damn he might be the best player in
football like you're you're watching
this and he never ever stops no he never
stops right I I I think you know like
his top end like you know ultimate like
talent I don't think it's quite as good
as maybe TJ watt or Micah Parsons or
Nick
Bosa uh or uh miles Garrett right I'm
I'm going to quite put him there I think
he's maybe just a notch below for me as
far as pure physical gifts but I think
the point to you make it's the instincts
it's the tenacity it's the craziness and
it's the fact that you know those other
guys I mentioned they can press on the
gas pedal 100 miles per hour but they
need to take a few plays off every now
and then Max Crosby can go 97 miles per
hour the whole game and never take one
play off and I think that's what I'm
Amazed by really is just is the fact of
how he can just red you know red needle
it all game long phenomenal football
player and it does feel like finally
this year people have realized how damn
good he is and you're right stats are
overrated you know I'm big into the F
the playup stat they need to make that
in the NFL you know the guy who ruined
the play doesn't get credit for it you
know and he's a guy that ruins a lot of
plays for that Raiders defense Chris
Sims pro football talk live co-host his
podcast called
unbuttoned Dak Prescott's getting some
MVP love but I would um caution the
voters let's look at those stats that
he's put up against some really bad
teams I want to see him in big games I
want to see see him that and and Jaylen
Herz is your MVP I I think the front
runner right now according to Vegas but
Dak it feels like we want to shoe horn
him in there because he's the Cowboy
quarterback uh and I think he's played
well but I don't know I mean let's see
what you do against the Eagles let let's
see what you do in these big games you
know what happened against the ners they
got roughed up you so if you want to win
an MVP and I still think it's open to
win then you better win some of these
big games here and be and perform big in
those games I I totally fair I think
your assessment there that that's been
the problem I think a little bit over
the last two years it's just in some of
the biggest moments Dak Prescott hasn't
played his best right and you know you
bring up a point yeah he's shoe hard in
there because he's the Dallas Cowboys
quarterback well he also gets a lot of
crap because he's the Dallas CB
quarterback too so I think you got to
you know take that into account uh but
he's playing phenomenal football he is
and I think think you know more than
what I argued early in the year a little
bit in his defense where I know it
wasn't perfect but like I did the you
know I do my unbutton podcast on
Wednesday as they call it the what the f
happen podcast right because I deep dive
into film and I watch it and I watch
that 49ers game back early in the year
and what I would tell a lot of people is
if you and you know me and Todd Fritz
and we all sat down and and we watched
the the film together you'd go well damn
really there wasn't one person open that
whole damn game and the offense attack
couldn't have been more bland and simple
let alone that that time of the year
they were the shortest passing team in
football to me the biggest difference is
they've opened the field up a little bit
and he is a great down the- field
thrower and he doesn't blink in under
pressure or with the pocket collapsing
that's what he's at his best but I think
your point that you make is is real the
final finishing touches is he's got to
play good against some of the elite
teams in football and show us he can
pull off some wins against them and I
think then he becomes a real big- time
legit MVP Contender people seem to be
mixed on Justin fields of what the Bears
do moving forward and you know we've had
analysts who've said hey I would stay
with him I would bypass Caleb Williams
or Drake May um maybe trade that first
pick that you're going to get from
Carolina but I think you're going to get
more expensive the decision's more
expensive with Justin Fields cuz you're
going to eventually have to pick up that
fifth year option then you have to start
to pay him and then now you've missed
out on this whole rookie contract
situation if you're running the Bears
have you seen enough at Justin Fields
And if you have are you staying with him
or are you moving on it's it's a really
tough decision it is because there's you
got to make the decision right now yeah
it's it's i i i you're on the clock with
a number one pick you're on the clock
right now and I was one before the year
to say like you stick with Justin fields
and see what you can work with here cuz
he's got some Elite traits about him
that are special right you know his
running he's the best running
quarterback in football we know that if
you put me on the clock and I don't like
saying this yes I'd probably move on
with Justin F from Justin Fields I would
okay you know I I don't think they're
egregiously wrong if they stick with him
I don't but the other night you know in
that game itself was troubling enough
that that was but are you moving on to
Caleb Williams or Drake May what yeah
one of those two I I'm going to move the
Bears to me the the Bears are a team
that I would say watch out for in the
future right I don't know if they're
going to keep Matt ebra Flo or what but
you saw that game on Monday night they
got a big overpowering offensive line
they got a good tight end they got
Mooney and DJ Mo at receiver they got
good running backs they got some scor
touchdowns I well I think a little bit
early in the year was it was Fields
issues hit a group I'm talking about
Monday night because it because of the
throwing plain and simple that that's
it's it's all there is to it how many
replays did you see the other night
where he was under pressure or whatever
and you're seeing this sky cam View and
you're going damn there's somebody open
right down the middle GNA change you
want to stay with the guy who's been
doing this for three years I I don't you
know I would definitely tell you if I
stayed with him I definitely wouldn't
pick up the fifth year option like it's
okay not to pick up a fifth year option
these are Big Boys they're making lots
of money it's okay to say we're going to
evaluate you one more year and see where
it goes like the Giants did to Daniel
Jones I think it's the proper thing to
do there so if that's what they want to
do but if you made me choose right now
no I would probably move on to go to one
of the two guys you know TV scouting as
far as Caleb Williams or Drake May I'd
probably go on to one of those two guys
yes all uh one last question here if CJ
strad was in Carolina and Bryce young
was in Houston yeah finish that sentence
uh it it it would look a lot different
Carolina would be better and Houston
wouldn't be as good you know that that's
plain and simp CJ strout Dan there's a
reason and I know I've been wrong other
years right I've been right more than
I've been wrong though and T I had CJ
Str in tier one by himself no I know
that know his ability to throw and
everybody is seeing it now and move in
the pocket six sense type of moves and
the way he played last week they didn't
run the ball people weren't open and he
just carried the freaking team like a
superstar he is special right Bryce
young needs a certain formula around him
he needs they need to spread the field
they need weapons it needs to be more
like the Tua kind of version Alabama he
needs well that that's a little bit you
know for lack of a better way to say it
yes where CJ strad can run any offense
and it doesn't matter you know now
they're better in Houston than they are
in Carolina I understand that uh but I
do think you know you switch teams
things will look a little different
Bryce young as slick as he is and all
that I like a lot right but his arm it's
it's average for the NFL and then the
other thing is like we talked about
during the draft time as quick as his
releases and the decisions are he loses
time on the back end of plays because he
can't stand in the pocket and make
throws with people bearing down on or
about to hit him he has a lot of ducking
and chucking that way because he's got
to save himself to wear plays where I go
oh if he was CJ strout he would have
just stand in there and take a shot and
he did the 20 yard out route Bryce young
has not afforded that luxury because
when he gets hit he gets ragal and he's
got to protect himself that way and
that's always what was scary to me about
him coming out in the in the draft and
you were big on thear Jackson when
nobody else was I you you I've Had My
Moments you k you love Kell M though I
listen I'll go through it I I I had
momes and Josh Allen and Lamar right and
CJ strad and of course yes I had Zach
Wilson and I did Matt caral one year so
I've taken some you know slaps in the
face I would stay with the Matt carral
that might still happen there I don't
know if it's going to happen I don't
think it's going to I think I'm done
with that one and I'm done with Zach
Wilson I think too good to good to visit
with you as always thank you Chris
always uh Chris Sims always enjoy
talking to him his podcast is called
unbutton you can see him on football
night America our play of the day is up
next right after this